ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING.
I APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE WE RAN
REALLY.
OF ALONG US SESSION ON THE FLOOR
SO I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S --
PATIENTS.
ARM WHILE WE WE TRY TO GET
THROUGH THIS.
AT THE SAME TIME.
WE HAVE A DEADLINE TIME TO END
THE MEETING.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENS AT
THE SAME TIME OF STARTED LATE
I'LL WE MUST LEAVE AT ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE AND THE MEETING AT
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE SO -- WHILE WE
WAIT -- FOR OUR OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
GET STARTED.
ON ISSUE [inaudible]
ISSUE.
NINETEEN ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS -- OKAY.
THIS IS THE OUR DOMESTIC WORKERS
OUT REACH -- AND WILL
IT'S FOR INFORMATIONAL.
A NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN ON THIS.
SO WOULD LIKE COME -- MEANT TO
PRESENT PLEASE GOOD MORNING
SENATOR TO RISE SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
UPDATE.
AS YOU KNOW -- THE LEGISLATURE
TASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL ASIANS WITH PROVIDE
WITH -- STUDYING THIS ISSUE AND
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
STUDY IS DUE IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR HOWEVER WE ARE HAPPY I AM
PLEASED TO SHARE.
A PRICE PARTIAL AND PRELIMINARY
FINDINGS WITH YOU TODAY.
USING JUST ONE SECOND IS IS THAT
OKAY OKAY OF THE INTERPRETER
ASKED ME TO ASK EVERYONE. TO TRY
NOT TO TALK REAL FAST -- NOT TOO
SLOW BUT JUST AT A NORMAL SPEED
SO THAT HE COULD TRANSLATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU -- THE NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIANS AGE SIXTY FIVE
AND OLDER IS EXPECTED TO NEARLY
DOUBLE AND REACH ALMOST NINE
MILLION BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WHICH WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL CARE GIVERS.
WELL CHILD CARE WORKER-EMPLOYMENT IS GROWINGSLOWLY AND
THE NUMBER OF HOME HEALTH AIDES
HAS RECENTLY SHRUNK.
THE RANKS OF PERSONAL CARE AIDES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE RISEN
DRAMATICALLY TO OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND ARE EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO RISE BY ALMOST 35% A
YEAR.
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE MEDIAN
ANNUAL SALARY FOR PERSONAL CARE
AIDES.
IS 260-002-0020 DOLLARS ABOUT
ELEVEN DOLLARS AND FORTY ONE
CENTS AN HOUR. TO THIRTEEN
DOLLARS AND SIX CENTS AN HOUR
HOME CARE.
EIGHT I'D LIKE TO NOW SEGUE INTO.
HOW THE STATE WHAT THE STATE'S
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS HAVE BEEN ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE DOMESTIC WORKERS
BILL OF RIGHTS?
OUR LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
CONDUCTED A STATEWIDE REVIEW OF
CLAIMS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO IN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WAS AN
OVERALL STEADY INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF WAGE CLAIMS FILED WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER BY
DOMESTIC WORKERS.
THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS IN
OUR SYSTEM FOR HOW WE CATEGORIZE
THOSE SO WE DO URGE SOME CAUTION.
BUT ROUGHLY WE FOUND IN THAT
TIME PERIOD ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
CLAIMS FELL WITHIN THE CRITERIA
THAT WE THINK ARE IDENTIFIED AS
A DOMESTIC WORKER.
IN OUR EVALUATION OF THOSE
CLAIMS WE FOUND THAT WORKERS
REPORTED AN AVERAGE HOURLY WAGE
OF THIRTEEN DOLLARS AND SIXTY
FOUR CENTS.
AND THE MEDIAN WAS ELEVEN
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS.
IN THE YEARS THAT WE EXAMINE
THOSE.
ROUGHLY FOUR AND FIVE WORKERS
REPORTED HOURLY WAGES AT WORK
SEEDING THE MINIMUM WAGE.
HOWEVER ONE IN TEN REPORTED.
THAT THEY RECEIVE LESS THAN THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
WITH MINIMAL HAVING ANY OF THEIR
CLAIMS RELATED TO OVER TIME.
HOWEVER WE DO URGE CAUTION WHEN
LOOKING AT THOSE STATISTICS
THERE ARE MANY BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT US FROM UNDERSTANDING
THE TRUE NATURE OF THE DATA.
THEY'RE ALSO BARRIERS TO
ENFORCEMENT [inaudible]
I'M.
IT IS DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
FOR OUR FIELD ENFORCEMENT -- TO
ENTER THE PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE THAT IS OFTEN A CLIENT'S
HOME AND WE TYPICALLY ENTER
WORKPLACES -- THAT ARE NOT THAT
ARE NOT HOMES AND THAT HAVE.
A LARGER SET SET OF WORKERS.
THERE ARE ALSO CONSTRAINTS AND
BARRIERS THAT WE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHERE WORKERS
MAY BE HESITANT TO BRING A CLAIM.
THERE IS FEAR OF LOSS OF JOBS
AND OR BENEFITS SUCH AS ROOM AND
BOARD.
THERE IS A LEGAL COMPLEXITY SOME
OF THESE CLAIMS.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL CHANGES IN
STATE FEDERAL IN CASE LAW THAT
HAVE IMPACTED THIS GROUP OF
WORKERS MAKING MAKING IT
CHALLENGING WE THINK FOR PEOPLE
TO KNOW WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE.
IN TERMS OF EARLY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR GOING
FORWARD.
OUR STAFF ARE CONDUCTING A
SURVEY TO OBTAIN STAKEHOLDER AND
PUT ON OUR REGION EDUCATION
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SOME OF THE RESPONDENTS INCLUDE
MEMBERS OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT WERE REGIONAL.
INITIALLY REQUIRED AND
PARTICIPATED -- UNDER THE VISOR
ADVISORY COMMITTEE REQUIRED
UNDER THE INITIAL DOMESTIC
WORKERS BILL OF RIGHTS PURSUANT
TO LABOR CODE SECTION.
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO WE HOPE TO
PROVIDE FURTHER DETAILS THE
RESULTS OF THE SURVEY AND MORE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN WE
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JULY.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN UP THE FLOOR IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WELL FIRST THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR MAKING THAT EFFORT TO REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THE FULL REPORT.
A JUST ONE QUESTION IN THAT FULL
REPORT -- DOES THAT INCLUDE --
THE INVOLVEMENT OF ADVOCATES OF
THE DOMESTIC WORKERS YES OKAY
GREAT WONDERFUL SO YOU'RE NOT
LIMITED TO WHAT.
FORMALLY.
I HAVE BEEN THE COMPLAINTS NO WE
ARE SURVEYING ALL WERE ALL -- AS
PART OF THE SURVEY TO GO BEYOND
JUST WHAT THE DATA THAT WE FOUND
THIS THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS
AND BARRIERS AS WE MENTIONED --
WE ARE SERVING ALL STAKEHOLDERS
SO EMPLOYERS AGENCIES ACADEMICS
ADVOCACY GROUP WORKER ADVOCACY
GROUPS ETCETERA GREAT OKAY
THAT'S WONDERFUL [inaudible]
OKAY -- ANY QUESTIONS OKAY.
WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE NO OKAY --
RIGHT -- TO ONE OF FLORIDA'S --
THE DECORATIVE DIRECTOR MOORHEAD
IS WHO NEED US YET THE OF US BE
HERE TO PRESENT PLEASE COME.
FORWARD YOU ALL I THINK YOU CAN
STAY.
OR YOU WILL HAVE TO THE SIDE SO
SHE OPPORTUNE SAID THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU CAN STAY SIR.
YOU COULD SAY [inaudible]
ROOM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THE US GOOD MORNING
WHERE DOES THE S.?
YEAH WE KNOW PRESS ONE OF
FLORIDA'S.
THE NUMBER IS ONE OF FLORIDA'S
FOR LATER TODAY WITH THE BOTTOM
CRITICISM HE DOES YEAH THE BUS
WILL NOT ALWAYS FEEL DEVICES
SEEM VENUS A LOOK DON'T.
GET THAT I HAPPEN TO HAVE A NICE
TO MEET AND IS THAT ALL THAT.
HE Là IN A COMEDIC WHAT WE KNOW
THE ORDER THEY LIKE WHEN HE SAID
THAT ABOUT HOW THAT AS A LOT OF
THE CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ONE OF
FLORES I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MOORHEAD IS WHEN YOU
THAT'S THE ACT THE BASS.
A MEMBERSHIP BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
LATINA IMMIGRANT DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND THAT SERVES ON THE
STEERING COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION.
TAMBIéN JOINT UP TO A HUNDRED
OTHER LAST.
WHEN I'M IN LOVE WITH THE LAURA
EMAIL BUT IN A COMPETITIVE THING
ABOUT A LACK SMS TO NOT THAT THE
HOW THE WHAT IS THE LAST?
LETTER PRESIDENTE IN A STYLE
ALSO NEEDLES THEN AFTER THAT I
STILL NEED THAT MUCH AND I
LOOKED UP A HARDWOOD AS THEY
DON'T RUSH.
I AM ALSO A FORMER DOMESTIC
WORKER MYSELF A FOUNDING MEMBER
AND BOARD MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
DOMESTIC WORKERS ALLIANCE.
AND I AM THE UNITED STATES
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS.
IS THE LUCKY.
BUT I BELIEVE.
ATTENDED BY THE LAW THE PRESS
WAS THOUGHT THIS SCENE COMMITTEE
ON IS A LAW THAT IS.
CORRECT YEAH INCLUDE I'M NOT
THEY LOOK I SEE OWN YEAH KANSI
BUT I WAS THAT AGE IS LAST OF
THE HOW THE WHAT I THINK A LOT
OF THEM THROUGH THE LED THE VC
ON THIS BAND THAT IS NOT WHAT I
LIST.
YOU COMPLETE ME AND I AM HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
ASK SOON OKAY TO SEE ME AND
THINGS.
IN IT ESTADO SAID ABOUT A LOS
THE URANUS THE GUYS ARE SIMPLY
AN ATA HELLO DOES THAT DOES THAT
BUT UP WE HAD TO BE THAT LIA
IDEA.
YES AND MIDDLE A STOCK ASEAN
BILL.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WORKERS WHO WORK AS
NANNIES HOME CARE ATTENDANTS AND
HOUSE CLEANERS IN PRIVATE HOMES.
MOST ARE IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
IN THE STATE NEARLY TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS RELY ON DOMESTIC WORK
TO SUPPORT THEIR EVERYDAY LIVES
AND THAT NUMBER IS GROWING.
THIS UP WITH ANOTHER MAN THING
ABOUT HELLO DOESN'T KNOW THAT IF
INTENT WHEN I START YEAH BUT ONE
SOURCE AT THIS TO SEE ON THE
LEFT WITH THE SOON AS BASIC US.
DO NOT DO A CANONICAL LAW SAYS
THAT I HOLDEN ALL THAT IS
DIRECTLY ARE YOU THE THE WHOLE
THAT'S A LOT WELL YES BUT HE
MEANT THAT WE NEED A LITTLE
WHILE THE SOUND I DO YOU.
YOUR LAST YEAR ON HIS LEVEL THAT
IS THIS NOT -- PORTLAND.
UNFORTUNATELY DOMESTIC WORKERS
HAVE FACED A SHAMEFUL HISTORY OF
LEGISLATIVE EXCLUSION FROM BASIC
LABOR PROTECTIONS AND AN ONGOING
CULTURE THAT DEVALUES THE WORK
NOT RECOGNIZING IT AS REAL AND
DIGNIFIED WORK.
DOMESTIC WORKERS TODAY WHEN YOU
CAN RESTING BOOST YEAH.
CUANDO ETCETERA HANDEL OR KNOWN.
I LOVE AYE LUCK ASSEMBLY RATHER
THAN WAS TO SIMPLY OTHER ORDERS.
HE KNOWS HAVE IT OTHER THAN THEY
USED FORTY FOUR MY CEILING OFF
FOR YOU.
THIS ONE IS THE DMC A CARE.
THAT THE FIT INTO QUESTION.
HE CAN BE LESS OF A WHOLE
RESERVOIR EVEN THE IDEA MADE THE
I HAVE EXPERIENCE THE TRULY
UNIQUE POSITION AND POWER
DYNAMIC THAT DOMESTIC WORKERS
EXPERIENCE WHEN WORKING ONE ON
ONE IN THE ISOLATION OF THE
PRIVATE HOMES OF OUR EMPLOYERS.
NOT KNOWING WHERE TO GO FOR
INFORMATION OR SUPPORT.
IT IS AN EXPERIENCE THAT IS
TRULY DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
JOB AND ONE THAT THOUSANDS OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS LIVE EVERY DAY.
GLOBALLY THERE -- CHIP FOR THE
ASSIGNED USE THAT OCCURS SEVERAL
WHILE I CUT THAT IT IT SHOWS
ENOUGH TO HOW IT HAS IT ALL
RIGHT AND IT DOES MEDIA TO SAVE.
LIKE WHAT IS A PERMANENT THE
LAST WITH THE SOON AS THEY WOULD
HAVE FACED US FROM NOT BE THIRTY
AYE STORICA JEFF YOU TO MORE
LETTING ME THAT IS THAT I HOLDEN.
SH.
AS A LEADER I THOUGHT FOR TEN
YEARS TO PASS THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
DOMESTIC WORKER BILL OF RIGHTS
WHICH FINALLY MADE PERMANENT THE
RIGHT TO OVERTIME.
IT WAS A HISTORIC VICTORY THAT
AFFIRMS THE DIGNITY OF DOMESTIC
WORK.
SIN EMBARGO.
DURABILITY OUR LOCAL MEMBER ASK
IDEA CAN ALSO EVENTUALLY KNOWS
THAT IT SHOWS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND HAS JUST GONE
JUST LIKE HIS LEFT.
HOWEVER I STILL TALK WITH
MEMBERS EVERY DAY WHO DO NOT
KNOW ABOUT THOSE RIGHTS AND WHO
DO NOT EXPERIENCE ANY OF THOSE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES.
YES BOY BUT I WILL NOT A PROBLEM
PROGRAM UP AND A CITY IS LOSING
THEIR JOBS IF YOU'RE GONNA THOSE
WILL NOT REALLY THAT IN LOVE YOU
KNOW THE LAST OF THE HOW THE
WHAT I WAS IN A RUSH.
I AM HERE TODAY ADVOCATING FOR A
PROGRAM TO MAKE THOSE NEWLY ONE
WRITES A REALITY IN THE LIVES OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS.
IN PROGRAM ABERDEEN DADDY ALLEN
IS THIS IDEA BECAUSE HE OWNED A
GUN SAFETY CAPACITOR C. ON
-ARAMBULA.
THEY HAVE A HIGH LOTUS JIM PLO
IT ISN'T OVER SO HIS FELLOW DO
MINIMAL WHAT I SAY IS THRUST YES
AND FOR ME THAT.
REGISTER THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
PROCESS SO THAT COULD BE BECAUSE
YOU UNDERSTAND IDEALS.
GUY FURTHER PLACIDE YES THAT
COMES YOU'RE NOT AVAILABLE.
THE PROGRAMWOULD PROVIDE
EDUCATION OUTREACH AND TRAINING
TO BOTH DOMESTIC WORK EMPLOYEES
AND EMPLOYERS ON MINIMUM WAGE
OVERTIME SICK LEAVE RECORD
KEEPING.
RACK RETALIATION AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S WAGE ADJUDICATION
AND RETALIATION PROCESS THESE.
MENDOZA RUN IS THE C. HONEST
COMPANY BUT YES CA MORE IT'S
BEEN LAST GUY JUST KIND OF YEAH.
I CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE WHAT I
SEE PROVISIONS ONE THREE NOT
MANTLE'S Và CONOCER SO THAT IT
SHOWS. SEVEN MUSKET ANIMALISTIC
LYCIDAS SOURCES FOR CELS.
IN ONE IS GALA THE LAST TO COME
INTO MY YOUR TODAY MOST GILLIS
DNA -- NOT AS POLLS HAVE REALLY
THAT JUNE BUT PAID.
WHILE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE MORE ARE ON THE GROUND
EVERY DAY REACHING WORKERS AND
PROVIDING KNOW YOUR RIGHTS
TRAININGS WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
TO DRASTICALLY SCALE UP THESE
EFFORTS.
AND WE BELIEVE THE STATE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY AND A ROLE TO
PLAY.
IN FRONT OF MOTHER THE BECAUSE
YOU AND YOUR CONCEPT AND THOSE A
LITTLE LESS OF A COUPLE DOZEN A
LOT.
IS SIMPLY MADE POSSIBLE.
GIVEN THE SOCIETY OF THAT
INFERENCE THAT LET ME SEE THAT
IF ONLY BECAUSE THEY L<c.cyan>G DO.</c>
THE DOMESTIC WORKER RIGHTS
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAM
IS THE NECESSARY FIRST STEP TO
MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE
INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE WHAT FOR YOUR OWN FOR
THE MOST DIVIDE LEVEES ME THAT
IN CAL OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA.
WHICH ADDRESS YES.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE CANNOT PULL
DIGNITY AND EVERY CALIFORNIA
HOME THANK YOU.
OKAY -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHICH HAS GOT US YES -- THIS
MORNING WE PASSED A RESOLUTION.
WE ENDED UP WITH THAT --
CELEBRATED THE LIFE OF SAYS SUCH
I WAS AND THE FARMWORKERS UNION.
UP AND IN MANY WAYS I SEE THAT.
THE CONDITIONS OF FARMWORKERS
BEING IGNORED AND VULNERABLE TO
ABUSE.
WHILE A DIFFERENT VERY DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY.
AS YOU SAID.
IS SIMILAR IN THE SENSE OF
ALWAYS BEING TREATED AS AND IN --
YOU KNOW.
THE CIVIC AND POLITICS OF SAW
AND ABUSED SO I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HISTORY OF
ACTIVISM.
AND I THANK EVERYONE HERE ALL
THE DOMESTIC WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUR ENORMOUS
HARD WORK YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE COULDN'T.
THE BOTTOM OF THE COMMISSION WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOR THE MYSTIC
WORKERS HELPING US WITH OUR
FAMILIES SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY OKAY SHOW MORE.
OKAY SO NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT -- I THINK
WE HAVE FIVE SPEAKERS YOU CAN
SAY OKAY YOU CAN THE NUMBER OF
FIVE SPEAKERS.
OF WERE.
TRYING TO KEEP IT TO A MINUTE
PLEASE [inaudible]
AND AND THEN EVERYONE ELSE AFTER
THE FIVE SPEAKERS -- COULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES [inaudible]
MANY.
YES HI MY NAME IS MICKEY BROWN
BOOKER AND I'M A MEMBER OF A
HAND IN HAND THE DOMESTIC
EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
AND I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
EASY DOES IT I'M REGENCY
SERVICES.
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT THAT SERVES
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
I FIRST STARTED HIRING AND
EMPLOYING.
PERSONAL ATTENDANTS WHEN I LEFT
MY PARENTS HOME AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN TO GO TO COLLEGE.
AT THAT TIME I HAD NO IDEA ABOUT
THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS OF THEM
FLYING.
I HAD TO FIGURE IT OUT ON MY OWN.
AND I WAS FRUSTRATED WITH HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS TO FIND ANY
INFORMATION.
AND SO THAT I COULD BE A GOOD
EMPLOYER.
MOST EMPLOYERS LIKE ME.
I USE THE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
THERE ARE DOMESTIC WORKERS.
AND TO THEIR HOMES AND LIVES BUT
DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
TOOLS TO KNOW HOW TO BE FAIR AND
FIRES.
I SOME OF SUPPORT TO DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
RIGHTS EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF A PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY EDUCATION TO EMPOWER
EMPLOYERS. TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND TO UPHOLD
FAIR PRACTICES IN OUR HOMES.
IT IS VITAL TO BRING RESPECT
FAIRNESS AND DIGNITY. TO THE
MASTER WORK SOME BOTH WORKERS
AND EMPLOYERS ARE SUPPORTING
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE OF THE
OTHER MINIMALLY AMEND THIS SO I
MEAN BROTHER CHILEAN LOS ANGELES
IT THE MUSIC THE HIGHLIGHT OF
THE BEST [inaudible]
DILLON PATHETIC.
SO MY NAME IS A MONEY AND ON
THIS AND I'M ALSO PART OF THE
COALITION AND I WORK FOR CHU LAI
IN LA.
I'M ALSO A DOMESTIC WORK.
AND DOES THAT IN CHILE YOU'RE
NOT GONNA SEE ME THAT IT
SHOULDN'T COME WHATEVER HAS
ALREADY COME WE MAKE IT ON THICK.
BETTER YET GET A SCORE WILL
SCORE OUR MISSION TOOK ON MY US
IT WOULD BE THAT THE APPLE YEAH
LAKE ON HIM CON WAS GONNA
DECIDED OTHER LAND.
BEFORE JOINING TO LAUGH I I NEED
A NEW MY IMMIGRANT RIGHTS OF MY
RIGHTS AS A DOMESTIC WORKER.
BUT NOW THAT I'VE BEEN PART OF
SHE LED THE COALITION I'M MORE
AWARE OF MY OWN RATES AS WELL AS
HOW TO SHARE THAT WITH OTHER
PEOPLE.
AND IT ONLY CAN SAY YOUR WEIGHT.
YEAH SO FREE M. THE TROUBLE THIS
IDEA.
MLB AND FORCE YET THIS MNS.
A YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A COMMITTEE
BE SO THEY CAST.
INTO THE FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I WENT THROUGH A REALLY
TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE OF WAGE
THEFT.
AND THEY TOLD ME ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED HOURS OF UNPAID WORK.
YOU'LL FEEL A COMMITTEE ON THEIR
THAT IT JUST A COMPANION THE
COUNTRY.
BUT I QUE ECONOMY THE UNITED
COMMITTEE BEYOND ECONOMY.
I ALONG WITH OTHER JULY MEMBERS
I MET WITH THE LABOR BOARD -- SO
I CAN HAVE MY RIGHTS RESPECTED
AND I COULD GET MY MONEY AND
WITH THEIR HELP AND ASSISTANCE I
WAS ABLE TO GET THAT BACK. FOR
ME THERE ARE A WHOLE BUNCH HERE.
THE ENTRENAMIENTO YES SAY THAN
TO PICK UP ON THE MAKE IT I'M
YEAH LET ME THAT INTEREST
IMMENSE INTEREST HOW DOES UP
PROGRAM OR COUNTY SAYS UNIT.
IN COMMAND AYE AYE THEY ARE YOU
THAT HE HAD A FRIEND -- THROUGH
MY WORK WITH CHILEAN THE
COALITION I NOW UNDERSTAND MY
RIGHTS I KNOW WHEN MY RIGHTS ARE
BEING VIOLATED I DON'T WHICH IS
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I KNOW WHERE I CAN ALSO SEEK
OUT ASSISTANCE IN CASE THIS
HAPPENS TO ME ALL OF THE PEOPLE.
YOUR CARE OKAY COULD ATTY A
PROGRAM OTHER THE QUESTION YEAH
CONCEPT BUT I LOOKED AT IT TO
THE LEFT ABOUT HOW THE RIGHT
THERE OKAY.
I DO BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD PASS
TO MOVE FOR WITH THIS RIGHTS AND
OUR REACH WORK THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS CONSISTENT OFF.
BUT I'M FOR MY LETTER THEY MUST
ABOUT HOW THE REST KEPT ALIVE
UNICORN MOTIONS WITH IT IT JUST
IT BUT I GUESS IT BY CARRIER
CONESUS UNITS COME WITH CHAIR
LACK OF A LUMP ON MY THREE AND A
STAFF -- SO WE CAN INFORM OTHER
MEMBERS NOT ONLY CHIT CHAT LAB
BUT ALSO THE COLLISION BUT ALSO.
OTHER UNINFORMED WORKERS WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE AND WHEN
THEY CAN ALSO GOING GET FURTHER
ASSISTANCE AND HELP.
YES SOARED UP BUT I CAN WITHDRAW
THAT IT'LL SANDRA ALICE BUT BY
WHAT UP AGAIN A PROGRAM AND THEN
THE QUESTION YOU HAVE CANCER.
WHICH ADDRESS YES.
IT IS TIME NOW FOR OUR RIGHTS TO
BE ACKNOWLEDGE AND RESPECT.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME STACY CON ON THE NETWORK
DIRECTOR OF HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
MY PARENTS HIRED AN ATTENDANT
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN MY FATHER
WAS RECOVERING FROM STOMACH
CANCER SURGERY.
SO HE COULD RECOVER AT HOME
AFTER MONTHS OF BEING IN A
REHABILITATION CENTER.
IN TALKING TO MY PARENTS THEY
SHARED WITH ME THAT WHEN THEY
HIRED RENALDO.
THEY FELT UNCOMFORTABLE SETTING
AGREEMENTS AND TING OUT GIVING
HIM BREAKS AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
OTHER POLICIES THAT EXISTED.
SO MANY AND SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
COME TO HAND IN HAND AS
EMPLOYERS -- THEY'RE COMING IN
THE MIDST OF A MAJOR LIFE CHANGE
OR AN EMERGENCY.
COULD BE AFTER HAVING A BABY OR
IN MY FAMILY'S CASE WHEN SOMEONE
NEEDED.
ON LABOR STANDARDS AND FAIR
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES IS
NECESSARY NOT JUST FOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS BUT ALSO FOR DOMESTIC
EMPLOYERS.
HAVING CLEAR GUIDANCE TAKE THE
GUESSWORK OUT OF WAGE OVERTIME
AND OTHER CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF
AN EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP.
THE SUPPORT FUNDING.
IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS PROGRAM
SO WE CAN WORK TO ENSURE THAT
ALL TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS WHO EMPLOY.
CAN FORM COMPLIANCE AND
RESPECTFUL.
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THEIR DIM THAT
DOMESTIC EMPLOYEES THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU.
WHEN WHEN THE VS WINNER VS MENON
MAY EVERYBODY HAVE QUALITY?
STORY IS SO I MEMBER ELLEN
CENTER AND I WOULD NOT TOTALLY
TODAY ON FOR MUCH OF SIGN YOU
ALSO HAVE TO HAVE A HOLLOW FROM
ULTRAVIOLET OTHER LITTLE THAT.
SO MY NAME IS MARIA CLEAN AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE GRANT IN
LABOR CENTER.
AND FOR MANY YEARS I HAVE WORKED
AS A DOMESTIC WORKER.
NO I CAN'T COME ON IN HERE AND
THOSE ON THOSE NâNG ELSE
QUINDLEN ESTATE THEN N<c.cyan> SAFE</c>
MATHIS HE PRESS AYE YOU'LL.
PROBABLY HIT IN THIS THE
FAMILIAR FOR SAY SIGN YOU KNOW
THE LOAN IS OBVIOUSNESS.
ARE THEY ALL CHORE OUR CHAU IT
AWAY YOU ALSO LIMIT BY THAT ONCE
AGAIN THANK THAT PUTS THEIR MIND
THAT IS SO SIGNIFICANT OF THOSE
ALL ARTISTS FOR ORDER.
THAT DOES THAT ORDER.
SO.
I I WORK THIS OUT CHUCKY
ATTENDANCE FOR TWO CHILDREN ON
WHEN I BEGAN THE CHILDREN --
WORTH SIX POINTS AND THREE YEARS
OF AGE.
I WORK FOR THIS FAMILY FOR SIX
YEARS I WORK FOR THEM FROM
MONDAY TO FRIDAY FROM EIGHT AM
TO EIGHT PM.
BUT THEY WOULD ONLY PAY ME A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DOLLARS PER
WEEK.
THAT MAN I WAS GETTING PAY FOR
TWO HOURS PER HOUR FOR CHIPS
THAT LASTED TWELVE HOURS IN
LENGTH.
GOOD ON THEM WHICH IS ANYA
CYNTHIA I LOVE THAT I THIS BOOK
HE THEN ALSO VIA MAYES THEIR
CHOSEN THE OTHER ONE BANK ON
THAT IN FOR MY CA ON FOR MANY
YEARS.
I WOULD JUST GO ABOUT MY LIFE
ISOLATED AND WITHOUT PROTECTION.
I DO NOT KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT MY
RIGHTS OR THAT EVEN IF I IF I
EVEN HAVE RIGHTS AND THAT HE
KNOW WHERE TO LOOK FOR THE
INFORMATION.
ASSET ALSO I KNOW IT'S MERRY
WILL AIR ON CENTRAL I WHAT I
THAT THEY DON'T NEED FOR SCHOOL
BY YET HE HE HE POOR SOULS BY
YET AS OUR AUTISTIC ALTHEA.
SELECT YOUR MINIMAL BUT US OUT
OF FEAR OF YAK YOU SOME IDEA OF
MINIMAL.
GET AREA OF AND THE CV THOUGH
YOU SAY QUE YO APPALLED AT THEM
ON THAT AFFORDABLE SO DAYS BUT
THIS YEAR ON BUT TWO YEARS AGO I
JOIN THE GRANT TO LABOR CENTER.
AND THROUGH THEIR WORKSHOPS AND
EDUCATION NOW I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A MINIMUM SALARY THAT I
COULD HAVE BEEN RECEIVING.
NOW I ALSO KNOW THAT I COULD GO
AFTER THOSE FAMILIES BECAUSE
THEY WERE EXPLOITING ME.
HI MALAY THEM OKAY THIS CALL
MORE YOUR IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL
WELL I HAVE THE UTMOST GOING OFF
THEIR MOST MOST MOST DANGEROUS.
THERE ARE STILL THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE DO
NOT KNOW WHAT THAT RIGHTS EXIST
IN THAT THOSE RIGHTS BELONGS TO
US.
YOUR MEN KNOW IT BUT I SET UP
THE WHY AND I LOOK THAT'S YOUR
KNEE IAN YEAH MATT AND
IMPAIRMENT TESTS ON THEM IS THAT
IT SHOWS.
GET ALL THEY NEED THAT THIS
BATTLE FOR ME THAT I WHILE FULLY
MEANS THAT IT SHOWS.
HE KLM GALLO OWNER AND SEE STAND
MY A LOCAL MONEY THAT UP FOR YOU
IN WISCONSIN OFFICE HERE ON I
CAME TODAY BEFORE YOU TO BE
PROACTIVE IN MY OWN EDUCATION
AND IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF MY
OWN RIGHTS OF OUR OUR RIGHTS.
I WOULD LIKE DIGNITY I NEED
DIGNITY AND RESPECT FROM MY JOB.
FROM MY TIME FOR MY RIGHTS.
I I AND I NEED THOSE RIGHTS FROM
MY EMPLOYER.
FROM THE SYSTEM IN NINETEEN THE
FROM A COMMUNITY THAT SUPPORTS
AND STAND BY OUR PROFESSION.
IT'S FOUR DAYS OKAY UP FOR YOU
KNOW NOT VERY AXION DATA PROGRAM
ON IT THAT'S YOUR OWN YEAH
CONCEPT BUT I WAS THAT AGE OF
THE LAST THAT I FOLLOWED US THAT
ALL THAT.
IT IS FOR THIS REASON THAT I
SUPPORT I'M ASKING YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THE
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND THE RICH
PROGRAM. FOR THE RIGHTS OF THE
WOMEN WHO WORK IN HOMES DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
WHICH ADDRESS THE ESTATE THEM IN
THIS BATTLE CAM IF I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE POINT ANIMALS.
YES YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I AM HOPING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS HELEN OF REALITY.
MY NAME IS HELEN THE BREA I AM A
MEMBER I'LL BELIEVE YOU KNOW
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE.
AND A BROAD CARE GIVER FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
I'VE HAD MANY JOBS WHERE I WOULD
WORK TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
TAKING CARE OF SENIORS.
AND WOULD NOT GET PAID PROPER
OVER TIME.
I KNEW THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THIS PRACTICE.
BUT BECAUSE I DID NOT KNOW MY
RIGHTS OR WHO TO GO.
TO AN US FOR SUPPORT AND HELP.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF I SHOULD KEEP
QUIET.
OR COMPLAIN ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE THIS BROUGHT IS SO
RAMPANT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS THE NORM.
BUT IT IS NOT AND IT SHOULD NOT
BE.
WE NEED TO EDUCATE EVERY CARE
GIVER AND EMPLOYER ABOUT ALL
RIGHT OUR EXISTING RIGHTS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN TAKING FOR
GRANTED FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
I BELIEVE THAT KNOWING AND
UNDERSTANDING ALL RIGHTS US THAT
CARE GIVER AND DOMESTIC WORKERS.
IS A STEP TOWARDS RECLAIMING OUR
DIGNITY OR POWER BOARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OKAY SO -- AT THIS POINT I THINK
WE'LL.
BUT LET EVERYONE ELSE COME UP
AND INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
YOU SAY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
OR CITY AND SO THAT WE GET OF
TIME FOR EVERYBODY PLEASE NOTE.
NO COMMENTS WE DON'T HAVE TIME
AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAD.
YOU HAD GREAT REPRESENTATIVE
SPEAK ON YOUR BEHALF.
BYNINETY YES ME NUMBER EIGHT
THAT MIGHT EVEN FROM METAL
EASILY MEMBER AT A LOCAL LAKE
EVA YES THEY YEAH KEEP AN APPLE
YEAH WHAT'S THAT.
YEP TO STAY STANDING UP FOR YOU
[inaudible]
REPLACE [inaudible]
I KNOW.
THANK YOU BECAUSE THIS WAS TO BE
NAMES AND ORGANIZATIONS AND
CITIES [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT CENTER BERGEN DISTANCE.
WELL ONE OF THE S. IS THEIR MAIN
NUMBER IS THE RIVER THAT ALL
CLASS BINGO THEY LIKELY AT THE
LEADING OKAY IT IS A SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN THIS PROGRAM -- ACADEMIC BUT
I CAN LAWS HAVE FOR YOU AND FOR
FOR US YES.
OR NO ONE KNOWS THE AS MY NUMBER
IS MADERA YES SO YOU'RE GOING TO
SELL OUT A CANADIAN SEND A
SIGNAL TO A BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
LOOK AT THE RING QUE WHAT.
YESTERDAY I KEEP IT UP ALL BUT I
CAN ALSO FOR YOUR BUT ON PROGRAM
I DID DISCUSS THE ON BUTTON LE
EASY.
YEAH I GOT TO PUT A LIST OF ALL
BECAUSE I WAS ALONE.
YES YES.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ON DOMESTIC WORKERS AND
I OF I AM ON PARTS OF MALAMA WHO
THIS REALLY THAT SICK THE LAST.
AND WHAT CITY.
ARE FROM UNITS CITY.
MY ONE OF THE ADMIN NUMBER TO
SIGN MY NAME GOT ON HIM WHEN
IT'S ME THAT'S ACTIVE AS THEY
SOMETIMES FISCAL HE IS THE UPPER
HAND ON LAP REQUEST THAT BY
NAKED.
LAST I DON'T AT THIS TIME DON'T
HAVE AN AT THE MOMENT THE THING
I THINK FOR MOST YOUNG GUY GOT
THE WAY AND THEN MOMENTO BUT IF
WE DON'T HAVE A RATHER LOW BACK.
THE NECESSARY FRANCISCO I'M A
JOBS WITH JUSTICE WHICH SUPPORTS
WORKERS RIGHTS IMMIGRATION
RIGHTS.
AND I SUPPORT DOMESTIC WORKERS
RIGHTS IN EDUCATION PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING EVERYONE -- MY NAME IS
LAURA INVOLVED I AM A CARE GIVER
ALTHOUGH I'M ON DISABILITY LEAVE%
RIGHT NOW -- I'M A MEMBER OF A
FILIPINO ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE.
AND I SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST.
TO IMPLEMENT THE DOMESTIC WORKER
RIGHTS EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM I THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
WE NOTICED BONUS ON THE LAND.
IS THE IBM BUT ARE THEY MAHOOD
WHO KNEW THAT THE EVENTS EVEN.
IS THIRTY FIVE DAY LOCALLY THE
ONLY.
YOU.
BEN GOING UP FOR YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M MONEY AND GUNS BUT I KNOW
THAT A DEAL THAT I THOUGHT ABOUT
A LOT OF LITTLE THAT.
THANK YOU SEE THAT HEY ONE HEY
WHERE'D LET US SEE YES YES.
HI MY NAME IS RANDY MENDOZA
MCCALL STUDENT FROM WITH YOUR
CALIFORNIA LOCATED IN LOS
ANGELES -- MY GREAT GRANDMOTHER
MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY STEP
MOTHER ALL DOMESTIC WORKERS.
THANK YOU. ONE OF THE ADMIN
NUMBER THOSE AS KELANTAN HE
STARTED OUT IN THE SYSTEM OKAY
SUNY THAT'S LIKE THE US YES FOR
YANKEE A BOY YANDLE.
IT BUT 'M NOT IT IS HELLO YEAH
CONCEPT BUT EXTENDED LEVELS I
MUST ABOUT HOW AS A LAW AT SO
THEY OPEN.
IT AS IS. ONE MORNING MY NAME IS
ERICA TERRACE AND THEM FROM
MORAN FROM HAYWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE OF THE S. ME
NUMBERS BECAUSE OF A NECKLACE CV
BUT THEN ESCORT YOU VITAL SIGN
PHYLLIS IN WHICH I SUPPOSE OF
VINCE YOUNG [inaudible]
YES YES.
THANK YOU NANCY DO YOU THINK YOU
BROUGHT UP WITH THAT THE PART OF
A PUBLIC.
ADDRESS YES.
WELL LET ME NUMBER IS NOW THE
FRANCO ES STAVING GO THERE THANK
AND IT'S GOING -- TO THE NUMBER
IS.
I'M HELLA CV VERY WELL THERE --
BUT AS WE NEED AFFECT THE ABOUT
THE SAN FRANCISCO EVEN WHILE FOR
YEAH.
IS UP AT THE CEILING THE LOS.
CINCO ME ON A HOT AS HIS
ESPERANZA.
ALMOST HAIRLESS COME ASSEMBLY
SAMANTHA SAMANTHA THANK YOU
SAMANTHA YOU THINK YOU WITH
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARIA
SANTIAGO AND THEY CAM K<c.cyan> IS</c>
WHEN THE HEART THE BACK.
END THE IS BUT THE REGULAR
SUPPORT PORTAL AT THE MOST OF
LIFE.
IF BE CLIFF NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
HELLO WHEN ASKED ME NUMBER A
SOMEBODY A LOT I MEAN BUT A
COLLECTIVE OF THEM HENNESSY
DOMINION BUT ON THE LEFT ONE IS
YOUNG.
PEOPLE A SEVEN WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO USS BUT IS WHICH I'M.
GONNA SAYS.
FOLLOWING THE M. NUMBER IS THAT
IN THEM.
AND THEN WILL LIKELY YOU I'M
LOOKING AT IS THE LETTER IS
CLOSE THIS WATER IS WHICH WE
WERE NOT CASF DOES JUST THAT
THIS.
THAT'S JUST WHAT WOULD DIMPLE
PRESCHOOL ARE MOST EASILY THAT
UP WHAT IS YOUR THAT THAT ABOUT
HOW THE REST A LOT I MEAN NOBODY
IS EIGHTY SEVEN WILL BE IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE LEVEL IT GIVE THEM CREDIT
ELECT WHAT IS YOUR THAT THAT
ABOUT HOW THE REST.
HE THE BILL THAT THIS BUT ALMOST
CAN A COUPLE YOU.
YES YES IT ****.
WHEN IS THE PULSE ME NUMBER LET
EMERALD?
IS THIS BECAUSE OF BOYS ****.
WE WENT AS THE OTHERS YOUR MEDIA
MEMORIAL HAVE ALARM.
YOUR BILL THIS OF US IS GONNA LE
COLLECTIVE OF THE MORE HIDEOUS.
CAN I SAYS. ELEVEN IS THE OTHER
NUMBER MONICA MARTINEZ DATE
LIKELY GIVE THEM CREDIT.
YOU GET US HAS BEEN A SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN ESSENCE. ONE OF THE S. ME
NUMBERS OF THOSE OVER AGAIN AS
HE IS BETTER THAN THAT
COLLECTIVE OTHER MAHOOD IS A SAN
FRANCISCO DIRECTLY SEE ON IT
THAT I HAVE KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA -- THE LESS SAID
ABOUT THIS CLOSE UP FOR YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VENUS
GARCIA AGAIN FROM THE HEAD COULD
A CT.
AND I'M.
FOR JUSTICE AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROGRESS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARY
ELLEN NINETY YEN AND TO AND I AM
A DOMESTIC WORKER EMPLOYER.
A PART OF HAND IN HAND AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN A SEVENTY NUMBER A LOT IN A
KIND OF THE OTHER?
WOMEN'S COLLECTIVE ANIL.
DAY LABOR PROGRAM AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO YES YES.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BETSY
GOT IN US AND FOR THE WOMEN'S
COLLECTIVE ENOUGH FOR SAN
FRANCISCO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER IS COOLEY ADMIN GO
THEN LAMB OKAY THIS MONEY THAT
DAY MOORLACH THE SAN FRANCISCO.
GLASSES. ONE OF THE S. ME NUMBER
DAYS AND THE MONEY YES AND DEVIL
GIVING THEM A HOME SAFE AND I AM
IN FREMONT.
IF CLINTON IS GOING TO FOR THE
MORE BUT EVEN BEFORE YET AND THE
LAST HOMEOWNERS IN THE WEDDING
BEFORE WAR.
SEPARATELY LACKEY WITH THE
PINEAPPLE THAT IT KIND OF MASS
COMPANION ASKING US YES YES YES.
ONE OF THE NEW NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN BETTER BE ABLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
HE SAID BUT THEY LIKE WHAT ISSUE.
THE LOTTERY SYSTEM CRISTINA
FIFTY A RELIABLE YET HELLO.
IT IS AT THE HOTEL.
LASSEN STATE UNIVERSITY AND I'M
HERE SUPPORTING THE WOMAN'S
RECORDS RIGHT THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HELP AND YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I WAS THE ONLY NUMBER OF
MONEY CAME IN LOCAL GLADLY CAM
KßT ISN'T IT IS?
THAT.
HELLO MY NAME IS XENA LEVY -- I
COME FROM A FAMILY THAT EMPLOYS
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND THEY
DESERVE OUR RESPECT FROM LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANET HONG AND
I COME FROM US EVERY CISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M LEFT HAND IN
HAND AND THEY SUPPORT DOMESTIC
WORKERS RATES.
THANK YOU.
WHEN DOES THE MINIMALIST MEDIAN
A LAST MINGLING HALEY UP WE
ALWAYS THE CUBS?
IT S. AS PART OF ANY.
HI HELLO IN A STYLE.
THERE IS SOME ALUMINUM CAUSING A
SICK PEOPLE OTHER SOMETIMES HE
FEELS.
HI MY NAME IS MIKE PRIOR I AM
COMING FROM OAKLAND AND RESOURCE
GENERATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KATHLEEN COAL AND THE
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO I'M ALSO A MEMBER
OF HAND IN HAND AS A FORMER
EMPLOYER OF CHILD CARE AND ELDER
CARE PROVIDERS HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT.
THANK YOU.
IT JUST ISN'T IN SUPPORT I'M
FROM BERKELEY BURKE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA NACION
COMING FROM SAN LEANDRO AND I
WORK WITH FULL PAN OUT BECAUSE
FOR JUSTICE.
THANK YOU.
I'M MARVIN GARCIA I AM FROM
HAYWARD I AM THEY IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS RESPONDER AT PHILIP NOT
BECAUSE FOR US.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE ADMIN NUMBER THAT
MARINA.
THEN GOING OUT AND IS
ESSENTIALLY THAT THE ANTI LOCK
VIOLATE BUNDLE AND FORTY FOUR
SECONDS AM.
YES YES.
WHEN I SEE A?
NUMBER IS CREATING THEIR OWN SO
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RUN IT DOES
NOT.
CONNECTICUT ON THE SECOND TO
LAST THERE'S NOTHING WHO OPENS
YOU WILL HAVE.
NO SIMPLE YOU BUT I'M GOING TO
START AND MAKE.
HI MY NAME IS MODEL ONE AND I'M
WHAT SHE LACKED IN LA THANK YOU
CRISIS.
MINIMALIST GOT EARLY NUMBER NINE
AND THEN PUT THEM IN THE TO DO
NOT A STICKY BUT I CAN SEE YOU
IN CLOSE UP FOR YOU.
MATHIS.
MASSES.
HI MEGAN OR TEASE WITH THE
INSTITUTE OF THE CUSTOM PURPLE
OUT OF THE SORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA EITHER UPSCALE HOPING
THAT CALIFORNIA COMPLETES MONEY
WHERE OUR WORKERS RIGHTS ARE.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DONNA
SPIN I'M COMING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND HAVE A CHAT WITH
DISABILITIES WHEN THE PASS HAS
USED -- DOMESTIC WORKERS IN ONE
ON THIS IS A REALLY USE THEM IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU FOR INTERPRETING.
THANK YOU RENE BAYARDO ESSAY YOU
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS QUIRK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHARTER ALSO MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AMERICA YOUR SHE HOW THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I'M DANIEL MARTINEZ AND I'M FROM
CHRISTMAS EVE US IN OAKLAND
THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER IS STILL BE A LITTLE
BIT SO I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW OLD
ARE THEY LOW THAT.
HE FOR HIM OKAY THIS TWENTY THE
THICK THE U. S..
BUT I MUST ADDRESS IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THINK A SEPARATE
PLACE OF BOYS STOLE A NUMBER AT
THE US COMPANION ASK IN THIS THE
MOMENT DOESN'T WANT ANYONE THAT
GOT SAYS IN THE YES YES.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SERRA
LEEDOM I AM FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION MY FAMILY ALSO
EMPLOYED DOMESTIC WORKERS I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED TO NOTICE BUT
PLEASE A FELLA FEDERIGO THE
LOGIN SSN TO LEAD TO THE IN THE
LITTLE UP FOR YOU BUT I ESPANOL
YES HOT EAT THEM BE IN BUT I
HAVE GOT A LOT SIMPLER LOTUS?
GET FOCUS HAVE ALLOWED OKAY USE
THEM BEING KID AND I DO THAT BUT
WRESTLING CALL MARKET AT THE
HELLO MY NAME'S MEGAN WHALEN AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION I LIVE IN
OAKLAND AND MY FAMILY ARE ALSO
CARE GIVERS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIMBERLY AWAITING A
DAUGHTER OF A DOMESTIC WORKER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LOU THIS MARTINEZ
I'M WITH MORE MEDICINE NEED US
AT THE US AND OAKLAND SAN
FRANCISCO IN UNION CITY -- I WAS
RAISED BY DOMESTIC WORKERS AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO WORK ALONGSIDE
THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NO MORE UP FROM PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELL -- I WANNA THANK EVERYBODY
WHO CAME TODAY -- THIS IS MEANT
TO BE AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
AND  APPRECIATE EVERYONE WHO
TRAVELED. FOR HOURS AND HOURS I
KNOW EVEN IF IT'S NEARBY
PROBABLY TOOK HOURS TO GET HERE --
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD -- FOR TO
THE FUTURE ON THIS ISSUE AND I
PERSONALLY APPRECIATE OUR
DOMESTIC WORKERS HAVE HELPED MY
FAMILY AND BE ABLE TO ALLOWED ME
TO BE ABLE TO DO MY WORK.
AND CARRY OUT OF MY CAREER SO
THANK YOU ALL WHICH HAS GOT SAYS
THAT THOSE BOARD THEY NEED. FOR
BY DC BOD -- IN THIS THE PROCESO
DEMOCRAT THE GOAL IS GOOD JAZZ
WHOSE VOICES -- I THINK THAT'S
IT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH THANK
YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT -- LOOK
FORWARD TO THE TO THE FUTURE ON
THIS ISSUE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEMS
PROPOSED FOR A VOTE ONLY.
UP WORST WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP.
ISSUE [inaudible]
ONE OF ISSUED.
IN THE SAME.
ONE OWNER OKAY ISSUE.
TWO OKAY.
ISSUED.
THREE ISSUE.
FOUR ISSUE FIVE ISSUE.
SIX ISSUE [inaudible]
SEVEN ISSUE [inaudible]
NINE ISSUE.
TWELVE ISSUE.
THIRTEEN ISSUE FOURTEEN AN ISSUE.
FIFTEEN IN ONE VOTE.
SO SOME OF OKAY -- WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
I THAT ARE NIELSEN.
CENTER ON BURKE.
THANK YOU.
OF WITHOUT MOVE ON TO A SEPARATE
VOTE ON THE ISSUE DID YOU WANT
TO TAKE THESE.
ALL THREE TOGETHER.
TOGETHER OKAY SO THE NEXT VOTE
WILL BE ISSUE.
EIGHT ISSUE TEN AN ISSUE ELEVEN
IS THAT CORRECT OKAY GREAT SO
WHAT WOULD LIKE.
TO MOVE THAT [inaudible]
SENATOR -- WE GO BACK. TO TO
THOSE ISSUES I HOPE.
THERE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF
THOSE ISSUES.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY NOW -- PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE. EIGHT TEN OR ELEVEN ANY
ISSUES NO OKAY.
THANK YOU -- WE NEED A MOTION
REMOVED.
OKAY -- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MAN CHAIR YES THAT ARE NIELSEN.
CENTER NUMBER.
FIVE OKAY [inaudible]
GREAT -- RIGHT RIGHT OKAY WE
HAVE FIFTEEN MINUTES SO I THINK
WE'RE GONNA MOVED.
TO ANOTHER -- ISSUE WHICH IS.
FOR TO HOLD ARM RECOMMENDATIONS
HOLD OPEN SO COULD WE HAVE A
BOARD ON ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
GOOD MORNING ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE -- WANTED TO BE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT FAMILY
PROGRAM OF COURSE THIS IS -- GOT
A LOT OF IDENTIFYING.
COURSE IT'S GOT A LOT OF
ATTENTION RECENTLY PARTICULARLY
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCEMENT
OF HIS DESIRE TO IMPROVE.
THE PROGRAM.
I'M SORRY COULD YOU INTO DO SO
OF APOLOGIZE -- CENTER ON
PATRICK HEAD AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT -- WE HAVE OVERSIGHT
OF SEVERAL DIFFERENT DIVISIONS
INCLUDING -- THE STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM --
WHICH IS -- PART OF ACTUALLY THE
A PARENT OF A CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM -- RENEE
GIPSON -- IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
OF EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN CHARGE OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND SHE'S
HERE TODAY IF THERE'S ANY
TACTICAL.
TYPICALLY ENSURE THAT I BUT
SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED -- IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR WAS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BY THEN SENATOR --
KEWL -- THAT STARTED THIS
PROGRAM -- CALIFORNIA -- THE
PROGRAM IS COVERED OVER EIGHTEEN
POINT ONE MILLION CALIFORNIA
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S FUNDED BY A 1% ABOUT 1% IT
FLUCTUATES TAX ON EMPLOYEES THIS
IS AN ENTIRELY EMPLOYEE FUNDED
PROGRAM -- IT'S NOT JUST PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IS PAID BY THAT IT
IS PAID -- THAT -- 1% ALSO PAYS
FOR STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE --
WHICH IS THERE -- FOR WELL WHEN
OTHER INJURED ON OUTSIDE.
OF THEIR WORK RESPONSIBILITIES.
LAST YEAR -- IT'S SERVED OVER US.
TWO MILLION -- THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS -- PROVIDING
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS TO THOSE WORKERS
PRIMARILY IT'S PROGRAM HAS BEEN
USE -- FOR BONDING.
BUT IT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
BE USED FOR CARE -- PARTICULARLY
AS OUR POPULATION IS AGING --
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS CARE -- FOR
THE USE OF THAT BENEFIT FOR CARE
GO UP -- AS OF A LACK ACTUALLY
AS OF THIS COMING YEAR -- WILL
ALSO BE EXTENDING THE BENEFIT.
TO FOLKS FOR WHAT'S CALLED
EXIGENCY -- WHICH ALLOWS -- THE
FAMILY OF OUR MILITARY MEN AND
WOMEN -- TO RECEIVE SOME TIME
AWAY FROM WORK.
A TO TAKE CARE FAMILY AND THE
HELP OF PREPARE.
OTHER LOVE ONE FOR SERVICE --
VOTE WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE THIS
PROGRAM -- OUT OF FRESNO OFFICE.
WHICH HELPS US OUT AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS -- IT IS --
PARTIAL WAGE REPLACEMENT OF UP
270% OF WAGES IT'S ON A SCALE --
THAT OF OF FORMER ASSEMBLY MAN --
PASTOR A COUPLE YEARS BACK --
BUT ALLOWS FOR UP -- TO ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS --
FOR WORKERS -- A WEEK.
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
HI MARC MINUTES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- AS DIRECTOR AND
STATED CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM ALLOWS WORKERS TO
TAKE UP TO SIX WEEKS OF PAID.
LEAVE ANNUALLY TO CARE FOR A
SERIOUSLY ILL FAMILY MEMBER OR
TO FIND A NEW BORN OR KNOW THE
ADOPTED CHILD.
WITH CURRENT WAGE REPLACEMENT OF
UP 270% OF SALARY BASED ON
INCOME LEVEL -- SO THE PROGRAM
WHICH IS A COMPONENT OF THE
STATE'S DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM SUPPORTS CHILD
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CRITICAL
FIRST WEEKS.
OF OF LIFE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
PROVIDING UP TO SIX MONTHS.
OF PAID PARENTAL LEAVE TO BOND
WITH A NEW CHILD LEADS TO
POSITIVE HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN.
GREATER ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR
PARENTS.
AND LESS STRAIN ON FINDING AND
AFFORDING INFANT CHILD CARE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO EXPANDING THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM WITH THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT ALL NEWBORNS AND
NEWLY ADOPTED BABIES CAN BE
CARED FOR BY A PARENT OR CLOSE
FAMILY MEMBER.
OR UP TO SIX FOR ABOUT SIX
MONTHS I'M IN THE SHORT TERM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PROPOSES JUST THE PRESERVE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE FIND THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM
THIS CHANGE WILL ENABLE THE
STATE. TO MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT
AND EXPANDING.
THE PROGRAM IN THE UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR.
WHILE MAINTAINING AN ADEQUATE
RESERVE.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONVENE A
TASK FORCE. TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT OPTIONS TO PHASE IN
AND EXPAND THE PROGRAM THIS TASK
FORCE -- WILL CONSIDER SUCH
FACTORS AS COSTS.
FUNDING SOURCES IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE IN OTHER RECENT
LEGISLATION LIKE A. B. NINE AWAY.
I'M IN ADDITION THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONSIDER
OTHER CHANGES INCLUDING THE
ALIGNMENT OF EXISTING WORKER
PROTECTIONS AND NON RETALIATION
PROTECTIONS TO INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF ALL WORKERS TO ACCESS
THESE IMPORTANT BENEFITS --
FINALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS STILL BEING
DEVELOPED.
BOB BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU CHAD DOWNLOAD THE
LATEST BATTLE IS OFFICE I'M WE
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT SORT OF A
FEW REMARKS -- THE THE GOVERNOR
AND AND AS MR MEN AS MENTIONED
HAS MADE THE THE FOCUS OF THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND IT FAMILY
LEAVE.
THE IMPROVEMENT OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT ON N. AS A
WAY TO SORT OF ADDRESS THAT GOAL
PARTICULAR THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
AT LEAST CONCEPTUALLY PROPOSED
AT THIS POINT.
TWO LENGTH AND DURATION OF LEAVE.
AND MAKE POTENTIAL CHANGES TO
ALLOW LEAVE TO BE TAKEN MORE
FLEXIBLY SO SHARE ABILITY -- AND
OTHER CHANGES FROM CURRENT LAW.
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS WE WOULD
POINT OUT AS THE SUB COMMITTEE
CONSIDERS -- THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND PAID FAMILY LEAVE OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS IS THAT IT
IT THINK ABOUT WHAT.
ITS OWN GOALS FOR THE EXPANSION
MIGHT BE -- OTHERS HAVE
IDENTIFIED ALTERNATIVE CALL SUCH
AS ADDRESSING HOT MATERNAL
HEALTH FOR REDUCING THE
INCIDENCE OF POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION.
OR POTENTIALLY -- GOALS RELATED
TO LABOR MARKET OUTCOME
ADDRESSING THAT THE GENDER GAP
IN LABOR MARKET PARTICIPATION.
WHERE IS THIS POINT BECAUSE?
THAT THE GOALS THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
ULTIMATELY IDENTIFIES AS
PRIORITIES FOR THE PROGRAM
SHOULD DICTATE WHAT CHANGES IT
PURSUITS ARM.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIMARILY
INTERESTED IN INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO TAKE.
A FAMILY LEAVE TO BOND WITH A
NEW CHILD -- AT THIS POINT WE
ESTIMATE THAT ABOUT HALF OF NEW
MOTHERS.
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM?
TAKE PART IN IT AND ABOUT A
QUARTER OF NEW FATHERS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TAKE PART SO THERE ARE
SOME PARTICIPATION QUESTIONS.
IF THE LEGISLATORS INTEREST IS
AN INCREASING THAT TAKE UP RATE.
WE WOULD POINT OUT THAT. ONE
THING THE DURATION OF LEAVE
ITSELF MIGHT NOT BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE POLICY TO GET YOU
THERE -- ALTERNATIVELY IF TAKE
UP IS THE THE PRIMARY GOALS JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE -- LOOKING MORE
CLOSELY AT THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE FOR ALL WORKERS ARE
POTENTIALLY TARGETED FOR CERTAIN
WORKERS -- EXPANDING OUTREACH
EFFORTS. TO INCREASE AWARENESS
OF THE PROGRAM AND MAYBE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE THE LEGAL JOB
PROTECTIONS THAT THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS ENSURING THAT
THOSE ARE BOTH IN LAW AND IN
PRACTICE.
ALLOWING PARENTS TO TAKE THAT
LEAVE TIME [inaudible]
I'M.
IN ADDITION OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS THE ONLY OTHER
POINT WE WOULD RAISE IS THAT --
IN  RECENT REPORT WE'VE WE
WORKED ON WE WANTED TO GET A
SENSE OF THREAT PROVIDE SOME
THINKING FILLED THE SUBCOMMITTEE
OF THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO GO
ABOUT IT ACTUALLY.
FUNDING EXPANDED WE'VE BEEN
AFFECTS THE MINISTRATION IS.
PROPOSING A TASK FORCE TO LOOK
AT THESE ISSUES BUT TO SORT OF
THE STARTING PLACE.
ON WE HAVEN'T SCORED A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A
SPECIFIC -- PROPOSAL TO LOOK AT
YET BUT WE THOUGHT MORE BROADLY
I'M.
THINKING OF THE CURRENT
FINANCING STRUCTURE THE PAYROLL
TAX AND AND THE BENEFIT
STRUCTURE.
UNDER STATE LAW THE PAYROLL TAX
AS DIRECTOR ANY MENTION
FLUCTUATES UPWARD OR DOWNWARD TO
BALANCE THE FUND -- BUT IT'S
CAPPED AT ONE POINT 5% OF A ROLE
TAX.
AND SO ON CURRENTLY IT'S ABOUT
1%.
WE SAID WELL BY HOW MUCH COULD
BENEFITS BE EXPANDED IN DOLLAR
TERMS.
IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHILE
STAYING UNDER THE ONE POINT 5%.
YES JUST ONE QUESTION SIR BEFORE
YOU GO FORWARD OF COURSE BUT
WITH REGARDS TO THE ONE ISN'T
THERE OF MAX ON THEIR EARNINGS.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ALL EARNING
THAT THAT'S RIGHT RECORD YOUNG
EXPLAINED THAT THE CURRENT
PAYROLL TAX IS PLAYED BY COVERED
EMPLOYERS AT 1% OF THEIR WAGES.
UP TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR -- SO
PLEASE EXCUSE ME.
PARDON ME THANK YOU -- EMPLOYEES
PAY A PAYROLL TAX UP TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT INCREASES
EACH YEAR MORE OR LESS WITH THE
RATE OF WAGE INFLATION -- BUT
BEYOND THAT AMOUNT EMPLOYEES NOT
A PAYROLL TAX.
OKAY.
I'M.
SO I THINK THEY DON'T PAY OR
DOES THE IT'LL BE ON THE
EARNINGS ABOVE THAT AMOUNT SO%
JUST ON THE BASE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IMAGES --
IN THINKING ABOUT THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE -- WITH -- RAN SOME
SCENARIOS AND OBVIOUSLY SUBJECT
TO SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE
FUTURE BUT WE THINK.
THAT PAYROLL TAXES ON THAT
EMPLOYEES PAY COULD BE INCREASED.
UNDER THE EXISTING STRUCTURE --
BY AT LEAST A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
AND BUT NOT LIKELY MORE THAN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFITS.
OP WITHOUT.
GOING ABOVE THE ONE POINT 5% CAP.
AND SO THIS WE THINK IS A
HELPFUL MARKER OF AND HOW HOW
WOULD YOU DO THAT.
THE MONEY IS IT TOO COMPLICATED
NO IT'S THE FUNDING SYSTEM IS IS
COMPLEX -- BUT IS DESIGNED TO
BASICALLY CALCULATE THE PAYROLL
TAX RATE THAT IS NECESSARY TO
GENERATE CONTRIBUTIONS.
THAT WOULD BALANCE OUT THE
AMOUNT THAT'S WOOD IS ESTIMATED
TO GO OUT AND BENEFITS SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE OR THE GOVERNOR
IN THIS INSTANCE.
IF THEY WERE TO EXPAND BENEFITS.
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS WOULD GO OUT
AND IN THE SUBSEQUENT YEAR THE
AUTOMATIC FORMULA WITH
RECALCULATE WHAT THE PAYROLL TAX
RATE.
ESTIMATED NEED TO BE TO GENERATE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO COVER THOSE
BENEFITS SO THERE'S A SORT OF
CIRCULAR.
A SELF ADJUSTING MECHANISM
[inaudible]
I'M.
WE THINK THE ONE BILLION TWO TWO
BILLION DOLLAR MARK IS A HELPFUL
BENCHMARK BECAUSE AS THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED CURRENTLY
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS FOR
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
SORT OF GIVE YOU.
AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE.
I'M A COUPLE POINTS.
BEFORE SIR FINISHING UP HERE
THAT WE WOULD MAKE OUR FIRST.
ANY ADDITIONAL BENEFITS THAT ARE
PROVIDED.
WOULD BE WOULD RESULT IN HIGHER
PAYROLL TAXES FOR WORKERS THAT
THE PAY INTO THE TO THE FUND --
AND SECONDLY GOING BEYOND THAT
ONE TO TWO BILLION DOLLAR RANGE
EXPANDED BENEFITS WOULD REQUIRE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY.
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES.
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS HERE A QUICK QUESTION
NUMBER OF THERE'S A PROCESS
QUESTION FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
RECTOR HANDING CERTAINLY IS IT
IS IT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS THAT.
WE HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED THE
NECESSARY FUNDING SOURCES OF
WHEN WHEN THIS COME BACK TO US
WHEN YOU TO SPITTLE COME BACK TO
US.
SENATOR REID IN SOME WAY I THINK
OF THE TO HARM TO FINANCE FOR
SOME OF THAT -- TO AVOID THE
HARD TO BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
I THINK THIS GOVERNMENT IS
MOVING PROGRESSIVELY AND I THINK
YOU'LL SEE SOMETHING THIS YEAR I
THINK IT'S FAIR -- A WELL I
GUESS JUST TO BE STRAIGHTFORWARD --
A WE DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
DETAILS OF THE THE ROLE THAT AT
THIS TIME -- BUT WERE -- WERE
MAGICALLY THE TASK FORCE SHOULD
BE CAN BEING SEEN IN OVER THE
NEXT YEAR.
SOLD.
OKAY SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE
THIS UNTIL NEXT YEAR IS THAT
WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE.
AGAIN I HAVE A I THINK THAT'S
SAD.
I CAN'T CONFIRM WHETHER IT'LL BE --
NEXT YEAR UNDER THE SUN I I'M
NOT -- TO I'M NOT WRITING IN MY
CAL.
I'M TRYING TO GET SOME SORT OF
IDEA JUST ROUGHLY WHEN YOU THINK
THIS WILL COME BACK TO US.
YOU KNOW GIVE OR TAKE A YEAR.
I'D SAY YEAH I'M I CAN'T REALLY
SAY YEAH I I ONLY HAVE THREE
MORE YEARS ON THIS TERM SO.
OKAY ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
WELL THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT.
BECAUSE EVEN THE CAP CAN BE
CHANGED.
AND I TRUST THIS WILL BE
AFFECTED IN THE TRAILER BILL
CORRECT.
IS THAT HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT.
SENATE RIGHT I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY THE MECHANISM THAT
THEY'LL USE I BELIEVE THAT --
THIS'LL HAPPEN THAT WE HAVE THE
SORT OF NORTH STAR.
OF THE SIX MONTHS AS PART OF THE
FINEST CORRECTLY POINTS OUT.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL I THINK THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
THIS IN AN APPROPRIATE FASHION
TO SIT DOWN WITH.
A CONVENING OF EXPERTS ON THIS
ISSUE.
BECAUSE OF THE SENSITIVITY OF IT
BEING A WORKER BENEFIT -- AND
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
CONCERN TO MAKE SURE THAT -- AND
A LOT OF THE RACES THAT -- WE
HAVE FROM THE LA -- I KNOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WANTS TO
MOVE SMARTLY ON THIS ISSUE -- SO
THE EXACT VEHICLE IT WOULD BE
HARD FOR ME TO SEND.
THE FINEST YOU GUYS KNOW EXACTLY
AYE AYE I DON'T KNOW.
THEY COULDN'T POSSIBLY BUT
THAT'S IMPORTANT POINT.
IT IS A MAJOR POLICY.
CERTAINLY WITH MERIT BUT WE
CAN'T BE DONE BLANK CHECKS.
AND IF GOING TO BE AFFECTED THIS
YEAR THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
ACTION TAKEN.
BY THE BUDGET IN THE BUDGET.
AND ONE MAN ANOTHER COULD BE IN
THE OVERALL BUDGET TELL FOR
COULD BE IN.
AND THE IMPORTANT POINT THEN IS
THAT.
THIS CAN'T BE JUST INTERJECTED
LATER AFTER THE MAY REVISE.
AND OR DONE IN A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE THERE'S ALMOST NO PUBLIC
INPUT.
AND LITTLE KNOWLEDGE. TO THE
PUBLIC OR EVEN TO THE MEMBERS.
AT THAT TIME SO I WOULD ENTREAT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO BE AS
EXPEDITIOUS AS THEY CAN AS TO
THIS YEAR'S PLAN.
AND NOT JUST SAY WELL WE'RE
GONNA BET ON THE COMMON WE'LL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS NEXT YEAR
THAT'S A MAJOR POLICY DID YOU
PUT INTO EFFECT BUT YOU'RE NOT.
HAVING ANY CONTROLS OR ABILITY
TO ASSESS WE NEED TO BE ABLE
[inaudible]
ABILITY STE.
APPOINTMENT BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INTENT IS TO
INVOLVE THE LEGISLATURE --
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS JANA AND
I'M SURE YOU WOULD MISTER
HANDING YOUR THAT IS YOUR
REPUTATION SO I HAVE NO FEAR BUT
IT'S A QUESTION THAT --
SOMETIMES BECAUSE OF HOW THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS UNFORTUNATELY
CHANGE THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS.
THE KEY POINTS THAT YOU MAKE --
ANALYST OR HELPFUL TO THE TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT THOSE ARE THE
KIND OF A ROAD MAP.
AND THAT WE NEED TO BE
RESPECTFUL AND AS I FOLLOW THIS
THROUGH THE PROCESS THEN NAVI BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT IT THAT.
DIFFERENT SPOTS ALONG THE WAY.
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN THE
SUB MAYBE IN THE STATE IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OF COURSE HERE BUT
ALSO WAS THE BUDGET -- INVOLVED
AND GOES THROUGH CONFERENCE AND
TO THE END.
I HAVE A THANK YOU SENATOR OF
THE I HAVE A QUESTION -- MAYBE
YOU DON'T HAVE IT ALL TODAY.
MR HANDING WITH REGARDS TO A. B.
NINE NO NINE OH WAIT I KNOW OR
OR A REPORT.
WILL BE DO BU THAT'S NOT FOR A
COUPLE YEARS RIGHT -- I'M JUST
WONDERING DO YOU HAVE ANY
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION -- ABOUT
THESE.
YEAH CAN YOU KNOW THE INCOME
CATEGORIES LIKE WHO'S WHO'S.
A ADVANTAGE OF THE BENEFITS AS
THAT EXIST WITHIN WHAT INCOME
CATEGORIES -- SENATOR WITH WE DO
WITH THAT AND APOLOGIZE FOR
STUFF IN IT BUT IF IF THERE'S
MORE THAT I NEED ANSWERED PLEASE
LET ME KNOW.
THE LA WAS REPORT IS ACTUALLY
VERY GOOD WHEN IT COMES TO
TAKING A LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
INCOME LEVELS AND SOME OF THE
EXACT DEMOGRAPHIC SO YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE EXACT REPORT THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING -- TO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS COMPLETED IT'S A
I HATE TO SAY THIS BUT I THINK
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION MAKING SURE THAT
IT GOES ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
CORRECTLY -- BUT THAT TYPE OF
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANT TO KNOW SO FAR AS
A UTILIZATION RATES -- MEN WOMEN
A NEW FATHERS -- I WAS ACTUALLY
HAPPY TO SEE THAT -- OUT OF A
SMALL A BIT OF MONEY IT WAS
SMALL IN THE SENSE OF THE
LARGESS OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
ABOUT SIX MILLION DOLLARS. TO DO
AN OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO TRY TO
GET THE UTILIZATION RATE UP.
WE EXPENDED THOSE FUNDS -- AND
JUST FINISHED WITH THAT AND WHAT
I'D SAY IS -- WHAT I WAS
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF?
IS THAT FATHERS WE TARGETED THAT
GROUP -- THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
USING THIS PROGRAM AS MUCH AS WE
WOULD LIKE. TO TRY TO GET THOSE
NUMBERS UP THOSE CAME UP.
WHEN IT CAME TO LATINO
POPULATIONS IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATIONS WE ALSO SAW THE
SLIDE UP TO BECAUSE WELL THEIR?
OVERALL OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
WE SENATE SEEN A 10% INCREASE IN
THE UTILIZATION OF THE PROGRAM.
THAT I BELIEVE IS IN PART -- THE
RESULT.
OF THAT OUTREACH PROGRAM -- BUT
IF THERE'S ANY DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
MY DEPARTMENT IS MORE THAN HAPPY
TO SHARE OKAY GREAT I'M
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO PUT
IN.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT EXPLICIT
IN THE LAW OR IN THE PRACTICES
OF DISCRIMINATORY.
INTENT BUT THERE COULD BE A
DISCRIMINATORY AFFECT -- SOMEONE
THROUGHOUT AN OF STATISTIC TO ME
THAT TO BE LIKE 40% OF LOW
INCOME WORKERS PUT IN BUT DON'T
40% DON'T ACTUALLY UTILIZE OF
LOW INCOME WORKERS SO.
THERE MAY BE AN UPTAKE OF 10%
QUESTION IS WHO'S REALLY
UTILIZING THAT -- AND ESPECIALLY
IF YOU'RE LOW INCOME GETTING
6270% OF THE MINIMUM WAGE DOES
NOT ALLOW YOU. TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM
UP TO BE ABLE.
TO STAY WITH YOUR FAMILY TO BE
ABLE TO HELP -- WITH WHATEVER A
USE IS -- IS NEEDED SO THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES THAT ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED ME BECAUSE IF WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO REACH.
THOSE FAMILIES AND THOSE
CHILDREN ALL WE'VE GOT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S DONE IN SUCH A WAY SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
IF WHAT I'M THINKING IS CORRECT
INSTEAD OF EXTENDING OR NOT IS
INSTEAD OF BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
DEAL WITH THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
PERCENTAGE OF WAGE REPLACEMENT.
AND THAT LIKE I SAID THE 6270%
OF MINIMUM WAGE.
HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY DO THAT SO?
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION IF YOU
HAVE.
PLEASE SHARE SENATOR AND IF IT'S
OKAY WITH THE OTHERS ON MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SHARE OF DIRECTLY
WITH THE OFFICE RIGHT CAN REPORT
TO THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
WHICH IP FOR OKAY.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON OF THIS ISSUE
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO SENATORS MY NAME IS DANYA
CASSIDY AND I'M WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILY
COALITION AND WE WERE THE
COALITION THAT HELP PASSED THE
FIRST LINE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS.
ISSUE FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS AND
WE REPRESENT A WIDE VARIETY OF
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE'RE VERY MUCH IN.
AGREEMENT WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU KNOW WHEN WE WANT TO EXPAND
THIS LAW WE DEFINITELY NEED THE
JOB PROTECTION BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE BEING THREATENED WITH THEIR
JOBS WE NEED ADEQUATE REYES WAGE
REPLACEMENT OR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
SO CAN TAKE IT.
WE NEED AN EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM THAT FOCUSES ON LOW
INCOME NEW IMMIGRANT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FRESNO CARE GIVERS.
THE WIDE VARIETY PEOPLE THEY
COULD TAKE A BECAUSE THIS REALLY
NEEDS TO WORK FOR DIVERSE
FAMILIES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHARTER RAZA MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE JUST WANTED
TO BRIEFLY -- STATE THAT WE VERY
MUCH DO SUPPORT EXPANDING THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TOOUR HEARTS WE SPONSOR
THE LEGISLATION THAT CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO AND BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT THE BENEFITS OF
JUST BEEN INCALCULABLE TO
WORKERS.
AND EMPLOYERS THAT WE DO THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
DOES IN THE END MEAN REDUCED
TURNOVER IMPROVE JOB
SATISFACTION AND DIRECT COST
SAVINGS FOR A LOT OF EMPLOYERS
OUT THERE.
AND HOPEFULLY THROUGH THIS
RENEWED FOCUS ON THE PROGRAM WE
CAN START TAKING A REAL HARD
LOOK AT HOW WE FINANCE THE
PROGRAM -- ESPECIALLY FOR
TALKING ABOUT MAJOR EXPANSIONS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
THERE RIGHT NOW.
THE PROGRAM IS FUNDED 1100% BY
WORKER CONTRIBUTIONS AND THAT
ARM WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE
WANT TO BRING MORE BENEFITS TO
WORKERS WE THINK I MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO CONSIDER THAT.
THE PROGRAM DOES DIRECTLY
BENEFIT EMPLOYERS AND THERE'S A
LOT THAT WE COULD DO TO MAKE US
LOOK MORE LIKE OTHER STATES AND
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT DO HAVE
MORE OF AN EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH IS THAT THE D. I
FUND AS IT STANDS NOW HAS BECOME.
KIND OF A SAFETY NET FOR
EMPLOYERS WHEN IT COMES TO
THINGS LIKE WORKERS COMPENSATION
WHERE.
WE HAVE WORKERS WHO ARE HURT ON
THE JOB OCCUPATIONAL INJURY THEY
CAN'T WORK ANYMORE WHEN THEIR
PLAYER FIGHTS THE CLAIM THEY
HAVE TO GO ON THE DE I FIND
GOING TO DE I TO ON TO STAY
AFLOAT.
AND AS A THE IDEA IS THAT THEN
WHEN THE WORKERS CLAIMS FOUND TO
BE WORK RELATED.
THAT THE STATE THEN GOES BACK
AND GETS THAT MONEY FROM THE
EMPLOYER BUT OFTEN THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AND AS A RESULT THERE'S
WELL OVER A BILLION DOLLARS THAT.
SHOULD BE IN THE FUND THAT ISN'T.
THERE'S A SIMILAR ISSUE
HAPPENING WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WHERE IF THERE IS A
RECESSION AND OUR SYSTEM IS
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED AS IT IS.
THE THE LOANS THAT WE NEED FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GENERATE
A LOT OF INTEREST AND DURING THE
LAST RECESSION.
THE MONEY FOR THE GENERAL FUND
WASN'T THERE AND SO THAT MONEY
WAS TAKEN OUT OF THE D. I. FUND.
ARE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THEN WENT TO GO PAY
OFF THE INTEREST ON THE LOANS
THAT ARE THERE BECAUSE FRANKLY
EMPLOYERS UNDER FUND THE U. I.
SYSTEM AND SO.
IT HAS BECOME SORT OF A SAFETY
NET FOR EMPLOYERS THAT WE THINK
IS IS IRONIC GIVEN THAT IT'S ALL
WORKER FUNDED AND SO -- MUSIC
THERE A LOT OF THINGS TO
CONSIDER AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
WE LOOK FOR TO BEING A PART OF
THE CONVERSATION.
I'M SORRY I I WE NEED TO END THE
MEETING SO IF YOU COULD JUST SAY
QUICKLY YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND IT'S LIKE
SUPPORTER DON'T OR I WOULD BE
GLAD TO RECEIVE ON ANYTHING IN
WRITING THAT YOU WOULD GIVE TO
US THANK YOU.
UNDERSTAND MY AND GRAHAM A CIO
CALIFORNIA I LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH THE WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS MARIE GO
YOSHIHARU AT THE CALIFORNIA
PLUMMET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
PART OF THE WORKING FAMILY
COALITION JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
ON THE NEED FOR JOB PROTECTION
AS WELL NUMEROUS STUDIES SHOWING
THAT IT'S A BIG BARRIER FOR
WORKERS BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THANK YOU.
I'LL HUNDRED ALLIED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALSO WITH THE
WORKING FAMILY COALITION I'M
ACCESS TO PAID LEAVE.
HELPS ALSO PREVENT INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE THANK YOU -- THIS
MARTINEZ MY MOM HAD A SONY THE
SAFETY OF US IN THE BAY AREA.
HOW WE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA COALITION
AND WE REALLY SUPPORT EXTENDING
THE PROTECTIONS OF -- PARENTAL
LEAVE WHICH ALLOWS US TO DO OUR
WORK AND ALSO CARE FOR FAMILIES
AT THE SAME TIME THANK YOU.
WHEN I NOTICED THIS WHEN IS IT
THE REST IN A POOR YOU?
ASK.
THIS IS KIMBERLY ELEVATING THE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION WE ARE ALSO
PART OF THE WORKING FAMILY
COALITION AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL.
ALL RIGHT -- THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WE TRIED TO GET AS MUCH AS WE
COULD THROUGH THIS TIME BUT THAT
WILL TAKE UP THE OTHER ISSUES IN
THE FUTURE MEETING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
FOR WHENEVER.
LIKE I'VE.
TALKED ABOUT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA BE EXPANDING
IT THIS WAY.
LANS